soyons un peu sérieux défendons les
valeurs de marianne et la turquie déjà
debout
[Musique]
les sorcières murmure à mon oreille et
m'accompagne pour être honnête la nuit
on est plus honnête on regarde la vie
exactement aux mails et quand elle ne
peut pas se méfier
[Musique]
donc les huit jours comme ça que je fais
quand ils dorment jeune homme va de soi
donc moi j'ai toute la nuit quand ils
dorment pourquoi j'avais adoré ce
problème parce que je n'ai pas leur
tranquillité et comme ils sont puissants
ils ont peut-être la tranquillité que je
ne quitterai jamais de toute ma vie donc
en béton les puissants si nous voulons
obtenir mieux de leur part nous devons
être plus exigeant si nous n'avons pas
le pouvoir
nous avons la masse la masse des gens
qui n'ont pas le pouvoir à travers le
monde
c'est la masse la plus importante les
audiences est une exception c'est une
minorité
donc il faut qu'à un moment donné qui
nous écoutent la majorité des humains
[Musique]
bravo le sénat enfin
je voudrais commencer demain parce que
je l'aimé beaucoup elle s'appelait nuit
blanche s est jamais ce que ça vous
plonger dans l'univers d'autres
écrivains et je trouve que c'était une
formidable récréation est aussi un
apprentissage parce que je découvrais
vraiment parfois d ofer que je n'avais
pas lu avant et donc ça ouvre et
l'horizon et ça me manque
[Musique]